les français sont très nombreux à être
en colère contre le gouvernement lui
faisant porter la responsabilité de la
situation sanitaire dans lequel se
trouve aujourd'hui le pays dissipation
des nids mauvais choix le chef de l'état
en prend aujourd'hui pour son grade
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux une
mode à laquelle semble avoir cédé
plusieurs célébrités qui se sont elles
aussi lâché depuis plusieurs jours à
l'instar par exemple de l'ex miss france
elodie gossuin qui n'a pas hésité à
tacler le premier ministre edouard
philippe en direct dans la matinale
qu'elle anime sur rfm c'est vrai que nos
enfants en bas âge n'ont pas besoin de
masques tu as besoin de rester confinés
ce qui compte c'est qu'ils retournent à
l'école pour que les parents puissent
aller travailler c'est la priorité
je ne suis pas du tout ironique
peut-être un petit peu son côté l'auteur
compositeur didier barbelivien a choisi
une forme plus poétique pour tacler le
gouvernement s'est en alexandrins que
l'artiste a décidé d'exprimer sa colère
un changement de forme mais pas de fond
qu'il a décidé de publier sur facebook
bon appétit messieurs aux ministres
intègres qui confinait la france comme
on fait du vinaigre depuis bientôt deux
mois de ce confinement à défaut d'être
là vous savez faire semblant autre
exemple avec l'animateur vincent lagaf
qui se produit en live sur ces réseaux
sociaux depuis le début du confinement
il a lui aussi donné en direct son avis
sur la gestion de cette crise je n'ai
aucune connaissance politique mais je
vous jure que faire pire que j'en suis
pas capable des coups de gueule qui se
multiplient ces derniers jours
alors comprenez vous les people qui
attaque le gouvernement alors on vous
pose la question comprenez vous les
people qui attaque le gouvernement il ya
raymond qu'il va nous rejoindre qu'il
avait plus que 6% de batterie il va être
là dans un instant géraldine maillet est
ce que vous les comprenez ou pas la loi
en fait je considère qu'aujourd'hui il
nous reste qu'une liberté c'est à
l'hiver exprimer qu'on soit kippel soit
citoyen soit politique dans l'opposition
et même si ça paraît ce terrible même si
ça paraît inutile même si ça paraît
dérisoire
je pense que cette liberté d'expression
après tout on a le droit
on a le droit on a droit de dire ce
qu'on pense on a droit de dire qu'il ya
des approximations d'un droit de dire
qu'on ne comprend pas on a droit de dire
que c'est raté c'est ce c'est aussi de
nous ce qu'on prenne ou et je pense que
cette liberté crise on voit pas pourquoi
la parole de stands du jardin ce serait
plus ou moins valables que la paire la
parole de rené de gilles de benjamin de
l'année dernière andy goode raymond je
vois pas où est le problème
même si voilà on n'est pas des sachants
on ne sait pas
on a cru que ça l'a fait alors y'a un
des pipoles un peu imprévues qui
s'attaque au gouvernement c'est jari
l'humoriste était invité deux
changements il en a profité pour tacler
le gouvernement selon lui il ya un gros
problème de communication j'arrive au
nickel a dit regardez vous savez qui me
rend fou c'est le fait de ne pas avoir
d'informations j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre
on n'est pas d'informations de
gouvernement nous donne pas
d'information là on sait qu'on est
confiné le 15
là il va le président va baba va
s'exprimer seulement lundi mais d'ici là
on n'a aucune information ne sait rien
alors on a que des on prévoit on
anticipe mais je trouve ça dingue en
2011 soit incapable de mieux communiquer
sans déconner je trouve ça triste parce
que ça nous met en attente est en stress
et franchement on a autre chose à faire
que ça eh bien il ya des gens qui ghazi
sa joie turillon la solution ces gens là
il ya aussi voilà je vous lis ya aussi
des gens qui nous disent oui mais quand
les gens seront dans la rue parce qu'ils
auront mis de l'huile sur le feu est ce
que c'est eux qui vont venir défendre
les forces de police voilà il ya des
gens qui disent a aussi dit c'est très
bien d'ouvrir sa gueule mais après il
faudra faire le boulot derrière le
boulot de service après vente
c'est ce que disent les gens sur twitter
après voilà il y en a peu qui sont
d'accord et granit noir il n'est plus
rien en fait on n'a plus droit vraiment
dire non mais non mais vraiment vraiment
vraiment qui revenue c'est aussi comme
si géraldine tu as tu as le droit on a
le droit de tout dire tout d'un droit de
critiquer aulas droit de dire y'a pas de
problème moi je persiste et signe ce
gouvernement je lui en veux beaucoup
comme beaucoup de français mais je
persiste que ces accrocs il est pilote
l'avion on le laisse atterrir là les
people ils font des coups de gueule à de
francs et finissons pas au courant la
via fille dit je connais pas la
politique mais il parle
jarry dit je comprends pas pourquoi on
communique pas mais il communique pas
parce qu'ils avancent à vue donc c'est
facile de critiquer le gouvernement est
rémois aussi dans métro le gouvernement
bouclé géraldine il fait à vue on peut
lui reprocher les masses
parce qu'on n'a pas de masque on peut
lui reprocher le gel on peut lui
reprocher des trucs comme ça
de l'autre côté je suis pas là pour
défendre le gouvernement mais je suis
ici de sel crues sans précédent on n'a
jamais vu ça nulle pas aucun pays n'a vu
ça dans un aucun livre d'histoire cette
crise elle existe dans aucun livre
d'histoire c'est pas la peste c'est
c'est un truc unique au monde
le gouvernement il
aux gens restez chez vous ceux qui sont
payés 1800 2000 euros vous serez payé
1000 5000 6 il a augmenté le rsa il a
mis des primes de 100 euros pour les
familles ont dû pierre tarance ans il a
dit aux gens qui étaient sensibles vous
serez payé 100% parce que vous êtes
sujets à risque vous n'irez pas
travailler vous serez payé 100% alors
moi j'aimerais répondre à tous ces gens
qui mettent de l'huile sur le feu les
bénévoles qui se préoccupaient pas un
d'autres qui n'auront pas dans la rue
qui n'auront pas de problème derrière
mais qui sert juste à mettre de l'huile
sur le feu
laisser faire les choses tranquille
restez donc de votre donner votre avis
il n'y a pas de souci mais d'un autre
côté le gouvernement il fait ce qu'il
veut et on prendra les responsabilités
après les clippers est mort dans deux
ans pas de voter le vote puis les deux
tours c'est pas un tour parce qu'avant
au second tour avec des candidats qu'on
n'a pas choisi ses deux tours le vote
des français c'est ça qui doivent
comprendre aujourd'hui mais moi les gens
qui par son gouvernement
ça me saoule un peu parce que voilà on
peut reprocher les masques il ya des
choses qui sont faites et je finis après
je vous laisse tranquille mme vallée
j'en ai marre aussi d'entendre au maroc
ya des masques au portugal il ya des
marques grillades et masque ou un maroc
qui a pas de chômage ya pas de sécu
quentin quand tu es viré tu es viré ont
regardé ce qui se passe aux états-unis
au portugal ils ont demandé aux gens de
prendre leurs congés payés
l'état ne veut pas payer au portugal
pour arrêter de comparer à 90 centimes
par rapport à nous on nous donne nos
salaires à 84%
c'est quand même pas c'est pas un deux
poids deux mesures et pourtant dieu sait
si je suis pas avec ce gouvernement et
ils font des bêtises mais là dessus pour
arrêter de taper gratuitement et il faut
dire que l'annoncé ne pardonne pas il ya
quatre ans il ya peu comme raymond kelly
c'est bien de critiquer mais tu apporte
quoi en face tp vous êtes tous à
critiquer le gouvernement mais tv mettez
vous à leur place c'est facile de
critiquer mais il fallait faire une
carrière politique bande de cons merci
raymond bien dit bonsoir les people ont
tous des restaurants pardon les people
devrait fermer leur gueule ils sont dans
un autre monde et nous dans le monde
réel
les people ont la chiasse ils vont
bientôt être obligé d'aller bosser en
usine
mais mdr cirilli que les twitts il
arrange quel mytho
je comprends pas du tout les critiques
sur les gouvernements alors les pipoles
taisez-vous jeudi un peu tous là
barbelivien y at il envoyé son texte à
sarkozy si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire puisque didier par blizzard
regarder il a critiqué le gouvernement
aussi sur sud radio je dis tout ça reste
le dit marion regarde c'est parti
personne n'est responsable d'une
pandémie mondiale jeu direct le temps
que sur les troncs c'est comme demain
guerre nucléaire a l'air tout court mais
de voir que depuis qu'on est au courant
le puits je sais pas
mettons de début mars on n'entend parler
que des paroles on nous dise qu'il faut
pas faire qu'on arrête là mais personne
ne dise qu'il fonde à lire tu dis aucun
studio c'est qu'ils didier barbelivien
les dirigeants qui s'est couverte un
mois j'aurais voulu pour me dit tu vois
on est tombé dans un truc très compliqué
on a passé les lieux au plus tôt on n'a
pas si on n'a pas si on n'a pas ça
imaginez un peu le nez vous ment du
personnel hospitalier pour faire face à
un machin pareil quand on te dit nous
sommes en guerre
moi je vois bien qu'on soit en guerre
mais en guerre on se bouge le cul te
vois alors les people qui s'attaque au
gouvernement est ce que vous comprenez
ou pas valérie bénaïm on n'a pas eu
votre votre à nous avec ses mots et chez
effectivement on a le droit de parler tu
as raison géré a dit évidemment qu'on a
le droit de critiquer bien sûr pas de
problème mais simplement à un moment
aussi
moi je crois que il ya un temps pour
tout là moi je pense que d'abord une
sorte d'union nationale on est dans un
bateau titanic pour qu'on essaie de tous
est coupé de tout ça mais pour ne pas
sombrer et donc dans son effort
collectif
il ya un moment il est urgent de se
taire d'avancé de dire bombard content
d'y faire je fais après pourquoi il y
aura une enquête parlementaire pour
savoir si le gouvernement a merdé ou pas
et on aura les responsabilités des uns
et des autres avec les faits et des
vraies études
exactement
comme en mai entrait pour l'instant on a
un bateau qui a coulé donc ce que la
seule chose qu'on a tous à faire c est
comme un chant en même temps et après on
pourra dire la une des responsabilités
langue point de vue voir untel ou untel
parce qu'elle est tellement comment est
on a qu'on a les réponses parce que ce
moment là on a les faits on a les
papiers on a effectivement voilà alors
vous êtes beaucoup à réagir il ya
quelqu'un qui a des flots qui nous dit
ok ils peuvent s'exprimer avec humilité
plus facile d'avoir des solutions de son
canapé que d'être sur le terrain voilà
avec les difficultés il délire ce soir
on est le seul pays à s'en sortir si mal
à avoir une gestion catastrophique c4
lio qui nous dit ça répond la voix du
peuple
raymond président elodie gossuin s'en
fout elle aura une nounou son mari pour
garder ses enfants s'ils vont pas à
l'école qu'elle se taise puisque elodie
gossuin a réagi également bravo raymond
on est avec toi
voilà ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
d'accord avec raymond baba tu diras
raymond que le maroc a laissé le salaire
des travailleurs confiné et s'ils ont
une sécu et ils ont une sécu pour les
plus démunis
benjamin castaldi a produit non mais
c'est honnêtement c'est
en plus ceux qui s'expriment c'est pas
les meilleurs il enfonce des portes
ouvertes
je trouve ça vraiment lamentable ça n'a
aucun intérêt aucun intérêt et je trouve
que par contre je ne veux pas tirer
toujours sur les bleus puisque quand ils
prennent la défense de nos vraies causes
ça c'est très bien mais là en ce moment
allait à les enfoncer les par diagne a
pas de masque il n'y a pas de gel
c'est complètement nul sanaa un dôme il
ya un intérêt et alors là pour le coup
c'est vraiment pour faire le buzz
on parle de franchement lavizzari la
comique est de la communication du
président j'en ai rien à [ __ ] excusez
moi d'accord va travailler ma vie ouais
ben tu sais on est obligé d'être
d'accord que je disais tout à l'heure et
à ces gens là ils sont là de notre monde
et moi j'adore les people altidore nam a
érigé en activité dit que mes mots la
partie des offres de leur part ils font
des doctes initiés aux associations aux
offices au dos face à tout le monde
autant la lépi père il joue le roi et
c'est très bien au total c'est comique
troupier qui est qu'ils se donnent un
donneur de leur sort et qui après ne
trouva pas après le continent et
retourneront dans leurs chapeaux fleuris
et tous les violeurs
il a alors le chez-nous tranquille
laisse nous tranquilles les petits on a
déjà du mal à te torture [ __ ] et tu me
casses les couilles
parce que là bas rhinoise idée le
gouvernement il fait ce qui le nom
malheureusement il chez petit peu et je
sais qu'après le fessier que j'ai dit
non j'ai dit fais ce qui te ce qu'ils
peuvent mais après le code fille diana
comme parler du nurenberg déjà doit de
parler du rebberg de du corps en avait
eu un procès en appel et a déjà le
zurichberg de du corral a eu lieu il ya
de jean marie bigard notre ami aussi
qu'il ya un mois il n'avait pas hésité à
faire savoir qu'il n'était pas content
regarder elle apprendra ya que géraldine
et on n'a pas une fille encore regarde
message message au président de la
république
emmanuel macron président j'ai entendu
le ton discours dans la dans l'attentes
l'un militaire tu nous parles que tu vas
donner ta des beaux projets pour après
mais on n'est pas après on est pendant
président on épand dans la merde là on
n'est même pas encore au sommet au pic
on est les vagues les plus fortes vont
arriver il va encore y avoir plein de
morts donc nous ce qu'on attend de toi
qui est notre président et tuer les
seuls à pouvoir le faire c'est que tu
nous donnes un [ __ ] d'échéancier quoi
et tu dois pas le dire baca ce sera fini
on va donner des milliards de milliards
en symboles alors ya les loups qui nous
dirait mon merci pour ta franchise et
les stars à part critiquer pourquoi je
n'achète pas des masses pour les plus
démunis
il ya banon qui m'a dit bon c'est vrai
que tu as lu tout je ferme ma gueule
il ya mehdi qui nous dit envoie moi un
chèque si les d'anna si vraiment tu lis
tout mdr le plus
est-ce que les people ont raison
comprenez vous les attaques et paypal
qui attaque le gouvernement
gilles garder d'appoint d'eau alors oui
oui ou non oui oui je les comprends
pourquoi parceque bon certains disent
n'importe quoi mais d'autres sont censés
or dans ces cris je suis désolé ça a été
longtemps l'union sacrée moi j'ai
respecté et on a vu du côté
gouvernemental est d'ailleurs les
sondages d'opinion le reflète
ça pose quand même des questions il ya
eu des affaires moment donc les gens
s'interrogent et les people
emma il exprime l'opinion des gens de la
rue sur les plateaux télé beaucoup de
chroniqueurs qui sont pro
gouvernementaux et les gens de la rue ne
sont pas tous et les ti police expriment
une opinion que les gens du peuple
aurait pu espérer mais hélas très peu de
gens lors de ma parole est donc un scoop
il des choses sensées qui pose des
vraies questions
donc je suis assez du côté de gérald du
côté de gérald c'est pas mal ce qu'ils
disaient c'est pas mal qu'ils expriment
chacun a le droit d'exprimer son opinion
aujourd'hui voilà alors géraldine
maillet vous vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord et qui veulent voyager
je veux bien que voilà qui soit
responsable de tout mais c'est pas des
sous citoyens c'est pas dénoncer pas
tous des nantis totalement déconnectés
de la réalité dans le massif et plein de
choses par ailleurs cours ils
prêteraient dans les régions je vous dis
en plus cher et omar sy ils ont rallié
jean dujardin patrick bruel ou catherine
deneuve y ait une tribune les artistes
demandent la prolongation des droits des
intermittents du spectacle d'un homme au
delà de l'engagement cité aurait été
impossible à colère et on sait très bien
qu'on prend ça c'est très bien mais oui
mais voilà c'est bien donc c'est très
bien où elle merci à eux de prendre la
parole parce qu'ils sont beaucoup moins
du coup eu concerner que les vrais
intermittents qui sont vraiment dans la
merde et qui se travaille dans le cinéma
ou au théâtre dans la musique et qui ne
sont pas du tout dénoncé dans des
châteaux doré comment là comme je l'aï
entendu
donc non moi je suis désolé il ya plus
le café du commerce il n'y a plus la
machine à café
moi je après tout on leur demande qu on
combine le cheminement on leur demande
comment ils vivent cette crise de la
même manière tout à l'heure nous on
disait les stickers dans le métro c'est
utile ou pas utile je crois d'avoir un
point de vue sur les choses est sûre et
sur la vie je veux dire c'est à quel
titre
alors justement fermez vos gueules
justement justine henin groupe est sûre
vous ne perdiez voir evans et cafetiers
training joyeux dix ans il en a ras le
bol mixeur robert pitte ou pas mais rené
roy n'est que six thématiques rené
comment pouvez vous critiquez les people
qui attaque le gouvernement vous faites
pareil surtout castaldi c'est l'hôpital
qui se fout de la machine à la charité
j'avais décrit notamment mois bassidji
battitta banon alors à quai j'aimerais
juste audi que j'ai juste dit justo
l'ifrad encore la dernière fois gc oui
ah oui c'est vrai la politique sociale
j'ai jamais dit que j'étais content de
m'en aller loin excusez moi excusez moi
goc qua non mais attendez on peut
répondre pas bien sûr de hockey et la
maison le téléspectateur cantini qu'on
critique le gouvernement gégé est
expliquée exprimé un sentiment
d'injustice par rapport à celle sociale
j'ai pas critiquer le gouvernement
excusez moi alors d'accord tu n'avais
jamais m'arrêter quelques écoutes est
hébergé par contre il y dévoile alors
j'ai pas eu le temps pendant cette
émission aubin et juste pour finir le
pas parce que pour le coup là excusez
moi le fait qu'une pénurie de masques
n'est pas le fait de ceux qui sont
arrivés maintenant excusez moi c'est pas
du tout lors c'est pas du tout de leur
fait pas du tout bon d'accord pas
laisser leur dis que ça servait à rien
oui alors si on perd je vais vous
montrer parce qu'il ya certains qui
disent que certains en profitent pour se
mettre en avant
voilà et qui voit là ça leur fait de la
pub parce que personne n'y voit pendant
le confinement donc ils font des vidéos
et font des coups de gueule comme ça au
moins
or on parle de qu'est ce que vous en
pensez raymond c'est quoi la question
parce que j'entends que j'ai pas entendu
avec le casier du magazine aquila qui
disent que les people font ça aussi pour
qu'on parle d'eux voilà pour faire un
petit coup de pub
ouais non mais moi je pense que s'il ya
ça parce qu'il comme ils font rien ils
sont à l'arrêt ils ont besoin d'exister
moi je pense aussi qu'à ça tout à
l'heure vous vous dites oui c'est vrai
que nous aussi on critique mais ne
mélangeons pas entre dire on pense qu un
sticker sur une chaise de métro ce sera
pas efficace entre eux macron edouard
philippe
ils font n'importe quoi ils sont prêts
nous envoyer dans le mur on va tous
mourir c'est différent ce qu'on juge
nous évidemment qu'un aussi au juge
mais est-ce que ce qu'on dit là c'est
que les people parfois ils vont trop
loin et on leur demande pas de critiquer
on attend la fin
et comme a dit valérie et tout à l'heure
il y aura un moment des décisions j'ai
entendu aussi érodé le nuremberg
on verra plus tard mais pour le moment
donné nous ces [ __ ] de masques donnez
nous des protections et on sait très
bien qu'il faudra pourtant bossé c'est
ça qu'on leur demande
et de critiquer ça fait pas avancer le
truc de critiquer ça met de l'huile sur
le feu avait avec des petites gens qui
écoutent beaucoup les people et les
pipoles il regarde beaucoup les avis sur
internet
merci vraiment en plus y'a will 1000 qui
nous dit vous avez regardé des vidéos en
entier notamment celle de la gaffe car
vous sortir juste la fin ou des extraits
on les critique ans asimov surtout
venant de vous c'est vrai qu'il faut
mettre toutes les vidéos su assez
d'accord avec eux il ya quelqu'un qui
nous disent on déconne et à mentir à ne
pas anticiper se sont créés au dessus
des autres pays ils payent leur
incompétence la critique c'est la
démocratie dans tout ça plante grain sa
splendeur c'est vrai il en faut ces
mousses qui nous dit ça aux manies qui
nous dit la moitié des people ne vivent
pas dans notre monde qui peuvent
s'exprimer mais qu'ils évitent les
critiques et les conseils c'est pas leur
rôle face à un petit peu ce que dit rené
ya quelqu'un qui est d'accord avec toi
qui dis que c'est pas le rôle est un
people
gilles verdez pour moi cyril je reviens
à votre avant-dernier intervention sur
le tweet il faut s'enorgueillir de
critiques et de débattre c'est ce qu'on
fait ici et raymond quand tu dis nous
c'est pas pareil c'est exactement ce
concert mois souvent des critiques très
dures basse et des critiques qu'ont
pensé les gens pourraient le dire mais
qui est du bon parler c'est pas la
tactique est finalement on laisse le
finir on n'est pas en plateau là oui moi
je m'en félicite de sa reçoit people
je regrette que plus de gens modestes ne
s'explique pas mais que chacun s'exprime
c'est pour ça qu'on est là français
qu'on est un pays démocratique et libre
tout le monde nous envie cette liberté
alors il ya des gens qui disent aussi en
ce moment je vous le dis 10 la meilleure
production et de ne plus la meilleure
protection et de ne plus écouter les
girons les journalistes et les pipoles
ils disent qu'il faut arrêter de les
écouter aussi way raymond tu voulais
réagir
non je disais nagent ils d'accord il a
raison nous on fait ça toute l'année il
a raison sauf que là on est dans un cas
unique pour n'a jamais vu donc on peut
pas l'avoir fait en plateau avant atp
mais on peut pas l'avoir fait avant ça
c'est unique ça n'a pas existé toute
l'année où on débat sur des émissions
toute l'année oui on donne notre ami
mais sur des cas de mort comme ça il ya
eu soixante mille morts aux etats unis
des morts partout dans le monde trois
cent mille morts
on n'a jamais on n'a jamais être débattu
sur 1,4 comme ça c'est unique au niveau
des fois ce qu'il ya c'est que commis un
acte illégal 10go souvent critiqués mais
nous on critique à notre niveau
le kicker comme une idée répond dans le
métro mais quatre coups sûrs et stickers
les vitraux cassés qu'il va pas dans le
métro elle a alors elle est là
le faisceau de rue mais qu'est ce que le
fait 99 morts revendication chère patrie
elle va aider les intermittences après
un très gros problème de santé
dernièrement catherine deneuve elle va
aider les arbitres à savoir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs 6 ou plus on
va voir le sondage merci les chéris
d'avoir réagi comme ça vous nous avez
fait kiffer 45% oui 55% non comprenez
vous les people qui attaquent le vernois
55%
les gens disent non mais